the Winter's expansion includes Shadows
of Rose the first piece of story DLC for
Resident Evil Village which picks up 16
years after the game concluded and
introduces Ethan winters's teenage
daughter Rose as a playable character
Rose has unique powers at her disposal
that make her feel distinct from the
many other protagonists in Resident
Evil's long history but it's the shift
to a third person perspective along with
changes in pacing style and tone that
set Shadows of Rose apart from Village's
main campaign it's more comparable to
the recent Resident Evil remakes than
either of Ethan winters's missed
Ventures but for as much as I adore
those games I'm hopeful this switch
isn't indicative of the series's future
Shadows of Rose begins with a discovery
that roses Powers have blighted her
formative years the narrative is light
on details regarding how her powers
manifest but sweating a white substance
is enough reason for spiteful classmates
to mercilessly bully her for being
different
my hours
came here to get rid of them
this just wants to be a normal kid and
rid herself of these debilitating
abilities so when she's offered the
chance to find a cure she jumps at it
with little hesitation however attaining
said cure acquires her to enter the
consciousness of the mega my seat this
fungal root is not only responsible for
the mold and Rose's Powers but any
humans who made physical contact with it
have had their memories absorbed and
stored within this conceit allows for
some fun surprises and also lets Capcom
revisit iconic locations from Villages
story albeit with a few key differences
the first Locale you're dropped back
into is Castle dimitrisk the resident
Lady of the house is absent this time
around but the castle walls are now
inhabited by a villainous version of
Ethan's Merchant Ally the Duke who
gleefully dispatches his own creatures
to Snuff Rose out these grotesque
monstrosities are similar in design to
the molded from Resident Evil 7 except
they have a nasty habit of sucking
Rose's face off whenever they get a hold
of her
to combat these face eaters Rose is
aided by an unseen entity called Michael
who can only communicate by Conjuring
written words that appear floating in
midair and on various surfaces Michael
manifests a pistol early on and he'll
provide you with ammunition and healing
items from time to time as well as
providing hints on where to go next his
presence is more crucial to the story
than the moment-to-moment gameplay but
the floating words add a fun wrinkle to
chase scenes as it feels like you're
being Guided by an ominous being despite
Michael's Aid killing a face eater
quickly Burns through your finite ammo
even if your headshot aim is true
the shambling eyesore soak up bullets
and although accurate hits slow them
down fighting a face eater Never feels
particularly satisfying due in part to
the fact that they all share the same
canned death animation the delightful
pop that so often accompanies fatal
headshots in villages main campaign is
notably absent so combat has a tame aura
that wasn't present before
fortunately one of your first tasks is
to awaken a power that lets Rose focus
on an enemy and frees them in place for
a few seconds using this ability is
limited just like your ammo but it gives
you the chance to unload some lead on an
easy target or use the opportunity to
run away adding a slim layer of strategy
to some encounters freezing enemies
isn't the most exciting of powers but it
gives you a rare advantage over your
foes and livens up the stale combat
attack being able to Halt the face
eaters progress is also key because the
slow deliberate pacing of Ethan's trip
to Castle dimitrisk has been replaced by
a chaotic Dash through the Castle's
walls the layout is identical in both
cases but familiar paths have now been
altered by the presence of undulating
pools of black mold that funnel you down
specific routes this makes navigating
much more linear than before but Shadows
of rose's frantic pacing makes the
castle feel somewhat fresh again
however much of the DLC doesn't offer a
lot to get excited about Beyond this
there's some light puzzle solving in
other locations a few jump scares and
any interesting themes in Rosa story are
only ever explored on the surfaced level
Resident Evil is known for being campy
and over the top in regard to its
storytelling so this shouldn't be
surprising but it's still disappointing
that it doesn't delve deeper into some
of the subjects it briefly alludes to in
a similar vein a lot of what is there is
never really explained and the story
feels very rushed which could be a
byproduct of its brief three-hour Play
Time mostly Shadows of Rose is just
forgettable despite its short length
it's also a shame that Rose's Powers
don't evolve until a final boss battle
that drags on far too long the second
half of the DLC is mostly devoid of
combat so they don't have a chance to
but the earlier sections could have been
improved by introducing a few more
wrinkles to Rosa's repertoire especially
since her Arsenal consists of a
decidedly weak pistol and shotgun combo
some situations call for stealth but
sneaking around as complicated by a
frustrating element of trial and error
aside from Shadows of Rose the winters
expansion also adds a third person mode
to Village's main campaign it works well
for the most part although it is a bit
jarring when cutscenes and certain
animations transition back to first
person
no no I'm friendly friendly I would
still recommend the original perspective
for those playing Village for the first
time but third person offers a
significant deviation for those wanting
a different kind of atmosphere when
revisiting the game again
ah
the other new additions concern The
Mercenaries mode which adds a couple of
new stages and a few more characters to
its score based time attack action Chris
Redfield is unlocked from the very start
and comes equipped with a different
arsenal of firearms than Ethan the most
notable difference between the two
however is Chris's Bolder punching Fists
get close enough to an enemy and you can
land a pair of devastating punches that
explode heads in a shower of blood kill
enough enemies and you'll fill up
Chris's Onslaught Gage which when filled
lets you deal more damage move faster
and utilize a Target locator to unleash
an explosive blast from the heavens
Carl Heisenberg and his massive Hammer
is one of the other new playable
characters diversifying the roster
further with a slow but powerful melee
build
smashing enemies into a pulp with his
signature makeshift weapon is always a
good time but you can always use his
electromagnetic powers to gather debris
and launch it as a deadly shrapnel
projectile you can also do the same with
a saw blade as though you're visiting
Half-Life 2's Raven home and even use
one of his hulking robot zombies to rush
any nearby enemies
however the best of the new characters
is of course lady dimitrisk the gigantic
Mistress of Castle Dimitris slices
through enemies with her grisly Talons
unleashes a swarm of bugs to defower her
foes and even crushes enemies by
throwing vanity tables at them similarly
to Chris she has a thrill meter that can
be filled to deal more damage and
increase movement speed she can also
summon her daughters to help out in a
pinch each of the new characters adds
more variety to The Mercenaries with
their distinctive play Styles and
transforms it into a mode that's worth
sinking your teeth into Shadows of Rose
might be the most notable part of
Winter's expansion but it's the
mercenaries that provides the most bang
for your buck
Rosa's tail is an uneven and brief
continuation of Winter's family's story
it successfully makes familiar locations
feel fresh again but doesn't do quite
enough with Rosa's powers to elevate its
action or make the experience feel
worthwhile the switch back to a third
person perspective is noteworthy and its
inclusion as an optional way to play
Resident Evil Village is a boon for
those thinking of replaying the game the
new additions to the mercenaries make
the winters's expansion worth it though
and while Shadows of rose has its
moments it doesn't pack enough engaging
material into its short time frame to
wholly recommend returning to the
eponymous Village
I feel different